ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre madame la Première
ministre aujourd'hui les Français sont
les mieux protégés telles sont les
propos de votre Ministre de l'économie
dans l'hebdomadaire challenge le 29
septembre dernier et là la réalité que
vit les Français au quotidien est bien
éloigné de ces éléments de langage
feutré la réalité des Français madame la
Première ministre c'est notamment les
lourdes difficultés que connaissent les
artisans boulangers les chiffres sont là
85% d'augmentation sur le prix de la
farine en un an 15% d'augmentation rien
contre septembre et octobre 215%
d'augmentation sur le kilo de beurre le
prix de l'huile a quant à lui quadruplé
cette flambée des prix que nous
connaissons et continue exponentielle
incontrôlées et dans bien des cas
injustifiés cette semaine en une nuit le
kilo de beurre a augmenté de 28%. les
artisans boulangers sont étranglés par
le prix des matières premières et par le
coût de l'énergie
certains en sont au point de supprimer
la fournée de l'après-midi pour ne pas
avoir à rallumer leur four et au bout de
la chaîne ce sont les Français qui
paient l'addition la baguette passe de 1
euro à un euro 30 et les boulangers qui
ne peuvent pas suivre son contrainte de
fermer mettant fin parfois au seul
commerce de proximité en territoire
rural les artisans boulangers ne sont
qu'un exemple parmi tant d'autres la
réalité qui est dénoncée par les
boulangers comme Frédéric Roy à Nice par
des industriels comme Thierry Dalbéra
dans ma circonscription mais aussi la
grande distribution comme Michel-Edouard
Leclerc c'est que cette inflation qui
tue nos entreprises et en plus de
considérablement le pouvoir d'achat des
Français n'est bien souvent pas
justifiée la guerre en Ukraine
n'explique pas tout les artisans les
commerçants les Français ont besoin de
réponses concrètes et d'action et je ne
parle pas de leur proposer de porter des
cols rouler alors ma question est la
suivante quelles sont les conclusions de
l'enquête sur la hausse des intelligenté
par Bercy en juillet dernier et que
comptez-vous faire pour mettre fin à la
spéculation afin de protéger
merci beaucoup